bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
comme chaque lundi
tout de suite on passe au sommaire une
large page eux consacré au cyclisme sur
piste le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueille
cette semaine les championnats du monde
les plus grandes stars de la discipline
seront présentes le public français
pourra voir en action les tricolores of
françois permis ce grégory baugé au
encore sans nucléaire
pour parler de cet événement nous
recevrons sur ce plateau arnaud courtier
directeur général délégué aux
championnats du monde et yann dujarrier
notre consultant cyclisme football magny
les hameaux s'est incliné sur le terrain
de bailly noisy ce dimanche sur le score
de 3 buts à 1
conséquence les saint quentinois ne
prennent pas le large en tête du
championnat de 2e division de district
badminton voisins bretons n'a organisé
les championnats nationaux de la
discipline nous reviendrons sur la
performance des yvelinois
et puis enfin l'émission tous les
résultats sportifs du week end
on commence 7,8 sport par l'événement
sportif de cette semaine je veux bien
sûr parler des championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
l'événement est programmée de ce
mercredi jusqu'à ce dimanche
la compétition a nécessité de plusieurs
mois de préparation les images sont
signés à william l
cinq mille spectateurs par jour 300
journalistes 38 nations des chiffres qui
donnent le tournis
cette semaine 18 au 22 février le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
va devenir la capitale internationale du
cyclisme à l'occasion des championnats
du monde sur piste pour accueillir les
fans venus des quatre coins du mond une
organisation millimétrée nécessaire pour
ces cinq jours de compétition
tout est prêt ou presque en train de
finaliser les aménagements vous voyez
peut-être un petit peu derrière moi
l'air centrale sur laquelle on est en
train d'aménager un seul podium où sont
les boks coureurs pour toutes les
équipes
puis à l'extérieur aussi bien sûr où on
aménage un petit village de partenaires
sur le parvis on a installé des
conteneurs de stockage des vélos pour
les trente six nations où 38 d'ailleurs
qui vont participer au championnat du
monde
et puis toute une infrastructure qu'on
ne voit pas forcément mais pour les
bénévoles les commissaires les
télévisions tous les ans qui vont
travailler pendant les championnats du
monde pour faire que tout se passe bien
dans l'air centrale située au milieu de
la piste le vélodrome dispose d'une
dizaine de boxe pour accueillir les
participants d'une infirmerie et d'une
zone pour les journalistes
sur leur central tout a été aménagé pour
l'installation des équipes premières
équipes d'ailleurs sont d'ores et déjà
là installée et s'entraîne donc là la
zone dans laquelle sont installés tous
les journalistes pendant la compétition
donc journaliste de presse écrite
principalement et si on se tourne de ce
côté là vous voyez les tables dans les
tribunes qui sont les postes
commentateur télé des différentes télé
on a 20 ou 25 chaînes de télévision du
monde entier qui font l'événement
des aménagements extérieurs ont
également été effectués pour ces
championnats du monde
des panneaux promotionnels ont été mises
en place sur les routes à proximité de
l'enceinte sportive le parvis devant le
vélodrome a également été réaménagé pour
la compétition sur le parvis on installe
quelques tentes dans lesquelles il y
aura les partenaires de l'ue c'est y
aura l'office du tourisme de saint
quentin en yvelines et puis un espace
france dans lesquels dans lequel le
public pourra se rendre aussi pour des
dédicaces avec les sportifs des
rencontres on va animer cet espace toute
la semaine lire aussi des petites choses
à grignoter
on est en plein mois de février dont il
y aura des crêpes des gangs des petites
choses comme ça pour un peu de réconfort
le vélodrome dispose encore de quelques
heures pour peaufiner l'organisation des
championnats du monde sur piste avant
que les vingt-cinq mille fans déferle
sur saint quentin en yvelines pour
lancer cette émission championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste nous
recevons ce soir arnaud courtiers alors
vous êtes directeur général délégué aux
championnats du monde et vous avez
réussi à vous libérer pour pour ce soir
justement malgré votre emploi du temps
surchargé mais exactement un petit
aller-retour maison donne un très bon
donc ça va merci à vous en tout cas
d'être là nous recevons également lien
dujarrier donc vous êtes notre
consultant cyclisme sur tv fil 78 cents
michael bonsoir
alors on vient de voir le reportage donc
ça a été effectuée la semaine dernière
le reportage a été fait la semaine
dernière
est ce que à 12 jours de l'événement
tout est enfin prêt tout est prêt
quelques détails sont en train d'être de
régler quelques installations quelques
câbles par ci par là mais tout est prêt
oui
et est ce que les championnats du monde
nécessitent vraiment un gros travail ça
se prépare quoi
quelques semaines quelques mois en amont
à ça se passe ça se prépare sur
plusieurs - il ya beaucoup d'aspects
logistique qui touchent aussi bien à la
partie purement technique par rapport à
la piste par rapport à la réception des
équipes des différents pays mais aussi
bien sûr par rapport à tout ce qui est
médias et je pense particulièrement à la
télévision les positions caméras les
cadres on en parle et l'alimentation
électrique nécessaire pour tous se faire
toute la préparation de la venue de ces
gens puisque on l'a on l'a dit plusieurs
fois on a à peu près 300 athlètes mais
on a beaucoup de monde qui travaillent
derrière avec les encadrements des
équipes mais aussi tous les stades pour
la technique donc ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui vont être là
pendant toute la semaine des
championnats et qu'est ce qui vous a
posé le plus de problèmes dans cette
organisation c'est quoi ces les
journalistes c'est lé staff peut-être il
ya eu un problème en particulier ou non
il n'y a pas de problèmes en particulier
et on n'a pas eu problème d'ailleurs le
seul problème si on vend trouve un
c'était le temps on avait six mois
seulement pour réaliser des championnats
qui normalement s'organise à peu près en
une année et du coup ça se passe comment
au niveau des équipes vous leur trouver
un logement ou vous apporter de la
nourriture ça se passe comment ou ceux
qui se débrouillent par e mail alors ils
se débrouillent plutôt par eux mêmes
mais au niveau de l'hébergement en fait
on les a accompagnés on les a guidés
on a des accords avec les hôtels de
saint quentin en yvelines une grande
majorité d'entre eux en tout cas et on a
guidé des équipes pour leur indiquer les
coordonnées des différents hôtels pour
qu'ils puissent facilement être en
contact et réserver leur hébergement et
les équipes sont principalement dans le
secteur sur 50 ans lui donner ses
environs elles sont dans le secteur sont
montigny à guyancourt à voisin attrapé
l'encours leçon sur tout le territoire
50 ans débit et est-ce qu'il y avait des
problèmes par rapport à vigipirate au
plan vigipirate qui a été lancé en
france
est-ce que ça a été une difficulté
supplémentaire où il y avait déjà
beaucoup de moyens de sécurité qui était
en place bison qui a donné il y avait
déjà une grotte sécurité mises en place
pour ce type d'événement effectivement
nous sommes
au clos niveau du plan vigipirate on a
simplement je dirais renforcer la
sécurité pour ne prendre aucun risque
on a eu juste oui on a juste eu par
exemple un changement de billet on avait
un billet qui avant pour être valable
pour deux trois ou quatre personnes
et maintenant on a un billet valable
pour une seule personne ça ça a été due
aux violents au plan vigipirate
oui c'est surtout qu'en fait le billet
vous permet de rentrer bien sûr mais
vous permet de sortir
pourquoi parce qu'en scannant le bien en
entrée et en sortie on est capable de
savoir en temps réel combien de
personnes sont sur site
et justement pour nous présenter une
journée type d'une personne qui viendra
au vélodrome là pour les championnats du
monde qui arrive un spectateur
moi je conseillerais d'arriver
suffisamment en avance pour aller
déjeuner tranquillement dans un des
restaurants de l'espace commercial de
saint quentin 2 seront ensuite d'après
appui au vélodrome puisque c'était à peu
près 900 m devenir un petit peu en
avance pour avoir le temps de venir
visiter les tentes des partenaires sur
le parvis et puis ensuite d'aller
s'installer tranquillement en tribunes
de profiter des épreuves ça dure
longtemps mais il y aura tout ce qu'il
faut sur site pour acheter à boire ou à
manger les spectateurs à la pause
peuvent ressortir du vélodrome s'ils le
désirent sur le parvis simplement hou
hou pour aller se promener et et venir
la deuxième session de soirée et vous
l'avez dit faut arriver en avance
il y aura énormément de monde pour cet
événement ça guichet fermé oui c'est à
guichet fermé et 5000 spectateurs par
jour donc il vaut mieux arriver un petit
peu en avance pour avoir le temps
d'aller au parking se garer
tranquillement de venir au vélodrome de
passer les contrôles de sécurité puisque
effectivement il y en a on l'a dit et de
s'installer et de trouver sa place sa
tribune s'installer confortablement
donc on voit à l'écran 5000 personnes
c'est ça le bruit saint geours voyez
5000 personnes tous les jours exactement
s'est plaint il restait quelques places
sont en train d'être vendu ce sera plein
à craquer et ian dujarrier vous vous la
sentez cette effervescence autour du
cyclisme sur piste ces championnats du
monde en tout cas pour nous le premier
la première visibilité c'est justement
le fait qu'on ait eu du mal à avoir des
places passé une semaine
ça a été ça a été très très rapide pour
la fin la billetterie a été prise
d'assaut
c'est le premier succès du promu succès
d'un chapelet du monde je pense que les
athlètes français sont très très content
de voir que le public français a répondu
on avait eu la confirmation après
l'échappée la france ou le samedi
le vélodrome était plein donc on savait
que pour pour championnat du monde tout
le monde tout le monde répondra présent
et il ya du jard y ait cette piste du
vélodrome allait vraiment hors norme
hors norme
ouais bah moi je ne m'en même plus
compte puisque ça avait le tir au tout
cas pour un outil c'est mon outil parce
que l'expression quotidien c'est mon
outil précieux quotidien donc j'ai pu
cette impression de d'énormes issime mai
mais les commentaires que j'ai pu voir
de certaines délégations
en arrivant sur sur le vélodrome sur sur
les réseaux sociaux m'ont fait prendre à
nouveau conscience que on avait un
superbe outil alors courtiers les
équipes ont pu tester la piste du
vélodrome à son arrivée la majorité des
équipes sont arrivées effectivement et
s'entraîne on est dans le calendrier des
entraînements officiels de l'uci ils ont
tous des créneaux donc effectivement il
tourne
du matin jusqu'au soir et effectivement
je partage votre avis on l'a lu sur les
réseaux sociaux avec beaucoup de plaisir
il faut le dire des commentaires
dithyrambiques élogieux de beaucoup
d'équipés qui trouve le vélodrome
magnifique qui trouve que la piste est
bien que la piste va vite c'est bon
signe
je pense qu'on va voir d'être très beau
championnat il ya également une
cérémonie d'ouverture
il ya une série mode et h ancien lieu
mercredi 18 ça commence à 19h ça dure à
peu près 45 minutes et on va pouvoir
voir quoi sur la lancée de sa demi
d'ouverture et bien je ne dirais pas ça
plaît oui oui c'est un peu un secret ça
va être sympathique on va présenter les
nations présentes urac quelques discours
bien évidemment il y aura les équipes
avec leurs petits drapeaux
comme d'habitude non parce que les
équipes sont déjà dans la compétition
donc les écrits qu'on ne ne défile pas
sur un champion du monde de cyclisme
mais on va les mettre à l'honneur quand
même par d'autres moyens et quel serait
le plus beau compliment qu'on pourrait
vous faire avoir le courtier sur
l'organisation de ces championnats du
monde de cyclisme mais une fois qu'ils
seront finis me dire que tout s'est très
bien passé
est-ce que vous allez pouvoir regarder
quand même quelques quelques courses et
j'espère absolument d'emploi du temps et
pas trop charger de si j'ai bien fait
mon travail pendant les championnats
j'aurais arriver à trouver le temps de
voir de trois courses ou alors ces
championnats du monde c'est un rendez
vous qu'il ne faudra pas manquer donc
dans l'organisation c'est également
rendez vous qu'il ne faudra pas manquer
sur la piste l'esti sprinteur tricolore
du coup doivent réussir des performances
sur ces championnats du monde donc nous
étions vendredi dernier au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous avons rencontré le dtn vincent
jacquet on les écoute
nous sommes avec vincent jacquet
directeur technique national ensemble
nous allons parler de l'équipe de france
et des championnats du monde sur piste
alors est ce que vous êtes prêt pour ces
championnats du monde sur piste parler
parce que j'attendais oui les athlètes
sont prêts et effectivement ça fait déjà
quelques temps que la pression monte
effectivement ça fait maintenant deux
mois plus de deux mois qu'on a en vase
clos et la suite à la dernière du coup
de coupe du monde de cali il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui les athlètes ont besoin
de rentrer sur ces pistes et ont besoin
d'en découdre les compétitions vont
bientôt arriver et très concrètement les
athlètes seront prêts et quels sont les
objectifs par des objectifs de chaque
athlète 7 gagner évidemment un
mais derrière ça on a effectivement une
dynamique qui va se lancer dès le
mercredi soir sur la vitesse par équipe
sur laquelle on souhaite le plus beau la
plus belle des médailles derrière ça on
a on a quand même des potentiels de
quatre à cinq médailles sur ces
championnats du monde qui nous
paraissent non pas ambitieux mais
raisonnable à voir et donc il faudra
assurer tout de suite les premières
courses
ah oui un là ça va danser la dynamique 1
les premières finales c'est mercredi
encore une fois sur sûre et vitesse par
équipes qui est l'un de nos points forts
effectivement on a travaillé depuis
depuis un certain nombre de mois à
restaurer la confiance de cette équipe
l'envié l'ambition et les 3 et les deux
sont prêts et en termes de médailles
vous comptez sur sur des sprinteurs en
particulier alors bon vitesse par
équipes évidemment là l'équipe qui est
présenté avec grégory kevin et et
michael on leur souhaite lors évidemment
et puis après sur la vitesse
individuelle tout peut se jouer avec de
très bons compétiteurs comme grégory
comme michael comme quentin
effectivement derrière on a on a au
chili le plus françois pervis qui nous
permet sur notre territoire de pouvoir
défendre le titre de champion du monde
quelle richesse je suis un dtn qui n'ont
pas qui a l'embarras du choix mais qui a
une densité en termes de sprinteurs qui
était très intéressante et ça serait un
véritable échec si vous n'arrivez à papa
a remporté une seule médaille
effectivement effectivement on est chez
nous on s'est préparé en amont
vous travaillez temps sur le screen que
sur l'endurance
ce serait une grosse contre-performance
de ne pas ramené de médaille de ces
championnats du monde tout en sachant
que pour nous l'objectif avoué il est à
rio
ici c'est un gros point de passage un
gros point d'évaluation de savoir où
est-ce qu'on en ait pour s'étalonner
face aux meilleurs mondiaux
on est chez nous donc on est ramené la
médaille
merci à vous vincent jacquey les
championnats du monde sur piste au
vélodrome de saint quentin m'immiscer du
18 au 22 février
il ya du jard y est vous l'avez entendu
l'objectif ses cinq médailles en oui
j'ai différé non je pense pas je pense
pas je pense que aussi bien en équipe de
sprint par équipes de fond les les
coureurs sont tous très motivés ils
n'auront pas l'occasion de faire un
championnat du monde
en france tout le temps donc il ya
vraiment une grosse grosse motivation
c'est leur outil ayant mené la dernière
pour pour les soutenir pour moi cinq
médailles c'est ce serait un minimum
c'est ça et est ce que les français sont
prêts pour ces championnats du monde sur
piste
vous les sentez prêt on a vu lors des
dernières coupes du monde que les
résultats n'étaient pas là
maintenant si on se réfère aux anglais
qui ne sont pratiquement raffin sont
rarement présent sur les championnats du
monde et ils sont là une fois tous les
quatre ans pour les jeux olympiques
eh bien on peut rater toutes les coupes
du monde qu'on veut pendant la saison et
être présent le jour du championnat du
monde
on l'a vu hier à l'exemple avec un
skieur de skieur de slalom
il faut être présent le jour j et c'est
ce qui c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer pendant pendant la semaine et est
ce que vous sentez qu'ils sont un peu
dans leur bulle on dit que laurent gané
donc leur manager que voilà que kylie
coup il les met dans un cocon c'est
vraiment ça c'est où vous le sentez que
langaney met beaucoup de pression
justement sur c'est quoi et qui les
enferme dans une bulle justement pour le
moment nous en tant que pratiquant
jusqu'à la semaine dernière on et on les
voyait encore au vélodrome et il est
encore accessible
on n'a pas eu cette sensation j'aimais
mieux que le bonheur de faire une un
entraînement avec laurent gané paddy
bayer mais dimanche la semaine dernière
il ya eu dix jours ouverts très sympa
donc pour l'instant nous on ne s'en est
pas rendu compte
maintenant ce qui est sûr c'est que la
discipline de la piste demande une vraie
concentration on ne crie pas
on ne prépare pas une course sur route
comme une course sur piste comme une
course sur route
on a moins le droit à l'erreur il faut
être là du début jusqu'à la fin présent
et la tactique est beaucoup plus
importante qu'il faut pas se rater le
courtier quand vous les voyez arriver
sur la piste du vélodrome ils sont
comment ils sont souriants
oui ils sont souriants moi je vous
dirais ils sont impatients mais vraiment
très très impatients ils ont envie d'en
découdre sur la piste ils le font à
domicile en france devant leur public et
pour certains à domicile véritablement -
qui habitent ici
donc voilà c'est là s'ils sont
impatients ils ont vraiment envie ils
ont très hâte que ça arrive encore plus
que nous alors il ya certes un pistard
qui vont arriver diminué donc pour ces
championnats du monde
je pense notamment à françois pervis ont
les coûts tout de suite été au micro de
terrifier 78 des doutes il y en a
forcément un petit peu parce que je suis
quand même
- je me sens moins fort que l'année
dernière à la même époque
donc là aujourd'hui je peux pas je peux
pas vous dire je vais gagner les trois
titres de champion du monde que j'ai
déjà gagné l'année dernière
je vais faire je fais avec comme je
voulais dire c'est comme ça c'est le
sport et puis moi je de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive je donnerai le meilleur de
moi même et je vais rien lâcher
il ya du jard y est vous le sentez
diminué on va dire sur ces championnats
du monde
françois pervis je pense qu'il bluffe et
j'espère qu'ils la fcc a agi seul en
bout je pense qu'ils n'en sait peut-être
le personnage qui est comme ça il n'a
jamais non plus été jamais été confiance
qui est arrivé l'année dernière les
trois titres il s'est presque venue d'un
seul coup il avait voilà donc il a
besoin de confirmer il a besoin de deux
soeurs rappeler aux championnats de
france il a raté sa la ville le temps à
deux vitesses le lendemain ils gagnent
et karine le lendemain ils gagnent le
kilomètre donc on sera prêt un seul
hambourg voilà et on sait que c'est un
vrai gagneur c'est un compétiteur d'un
bon mental avec un gros mental comme
laurent gané l'était aussi c'était un
vrai combattant
moi je pense que c'est sur la piste que
quand on aura les informations et puis
lors du 200 m déjà vendredi
et justement la relation avec laurent
gané c'est fait pour vraiment épanouir
encore plus françois pervis françois
pervis toute l'équipe c'est pas juste
françois c'est l'esprit l'esprit
combattant de laurent il va il va être
transmis à tout le monde
alors laurent il n'est pas là que pour
ce championnat du monde il est là pour
aller jusqu'à rio
ça va être un travail sur sur un peu
plus de deux ans donc c'est pas c'est
pas aujourd'hui qu'on va juger les
résultats mais les résultats deux jours
enfin pour ce championnat là ils seront
du fait que la motivation elle est que
ben on est chez nous c'est tout c'est la
même chose que comme ile de france 98
avec le avec le football quoi c'était
d'autres coupe du monde
ben ils n'ont gagné l'aller nos
cyclistes et bien ils seront ils seront
à la hauteur parce que parce qu'on est
chez nous et celui qui va arriver
également diminué c'est thomas boudât
sur ces championnats du monde
vous avez des nouvelles vous pensez
qu'il va pouvoir tenir sa place
l'âge n'ont pas de nouvelles j'ai appris
j'ai appris maintenant
son mât pas dire qu'il a fait une chute
à mayol on peut dire que c'est arrivé au
plus mauvais moment
est-ce que là si la douleur ne
l'empêchent pas de
ça ne le gêne pas il va être vraiment
être strappé c'est ça j'ai pas du tout
d'un fou là dessus
maintenant voilà pour moi si la douleur
ne le gêne pas pour pour rouler bien
peut-être qu'il voire un poil de
fraîcheur supplémentaire parce que c'est
arrivé il ya quinze jours de moins
d'entraînement c'est pas trop trop
pénalisant maintenant je suis pas sur le
vélo à sa place ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est une discipline qui est très très
difficile dominium avec six épreuves en
deux jours
très très fatiguant on verra on verra
par la suite quoi il ya également un
sprinteur qui va être revanchard sur ces
championnats du monde je pensais à
grégory baugé on écoute s'il était au
micro de télé fille 78 ça va en avoir
acquis aux championnats du monde à
l'étranger un bien sûr c'est chez nous
donc c'est un peu plus excitant mais
voilà je pense que j'ai une revanche à
prendre par rapport à 2006 et puis et
puis on sait très bien que moi de tous
les français qui étaient des aranoa à
londres ont envie de nous voir briller
dans quelques semaines donc voilà après
ça ne 2 2 passes et s'est emballée de
d'être trop excité par rapport à
l'événement il ya du jardin est ce que
vous pensez qu'il va être revanchard
justement sur ces championnats du monde
sur piste ici dans son pays pour pour
grégory de toute façon l'objectif il est
c'est rio 2016
je pense que depuis depuis londres
depuis londres il ne pense plus qu'à ça
il a pris il a fait son break qu'il a il
a eu besoin de se ressourcer pour se re
motiver pour revenir à très haut niveau
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui elle assure motivation qui
va aller chercher c'est parce que encore
une fois il est à domicile et lyon de la
montre où il a montré aux championnats
d'europe
ou bien c'était en guadeloupe ou en
martinique et en guadeloupe je crois il
avait pris le titre le titre là bas
aujourd'hui c'est l'étape du dessus
c'est le championnat du monde et ben il
va être motivé par le fait d'être à la
maison un petit mot également sur les
féminines il ya 110 clair qui est
attendu sandie clair oui bah là il va
falloir confirmer parce que enfin
pourquoi il a confirmé sa très belle
médaille demain c'est très belle
quatrième place qu'elle a fait à londres
je crois en vitesse il va falloir aller
il va falloir confirmer
c'est vrai que là ce serait ce serait
très bien de
rééditer cet exploit et puis après on a
quand même la vitesse par équipes aussi
où il ya une belle une belle carte
les filles a eu de montrer que peuvent
aller à rivaliser avec les meilleurs
mondiaux
les maires mondial c'est vrai que là
pour l'instant il ya un petit il ya
toujours eu un petit un petit gap moi je
crois aussi beaucoup on leur y berton
sur sur le biome toujours
ça va être aussi une belle épreuve
favorite je veux non mais je pense que
ben toujours grâce à la motivation et
puis c'est une fille c'est vraiment une
fille très très gentil très très très
sympa sur le sur le 1 sur l'omnium ouais
j'espère qu'elle pourra aller chercher
un très beau résultat
on referme cette large page consacrée au
cyclisme sur piste
merci à nos courtiers d'être venu sur ce
plateau merci merci également à vous et
yann dujarrier alors on vous retrouvera
cette semaine sur la piste du vélodrome
et lundi prochain pour les débrief donc
de ces championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste avec des médailles et des
maillots à fêter c'est ça on espère en
tout cas on passe ensuite aux autres
résultats du week end et du badminton ce
week-end à voisins-le-bretonneux la
commune organisé un tournoi national
plus de 350 joueurs et trèbes été
présent pendant toute la compétition on
écoute maurice paquet responsable des
jeunes de voisins-le-bretonneux une
soixantaine de clubs à peu représentés
alors les plus gros clubs s'il sait des
clubs vraiment à côté ça va être
montigny-le-bretonneux
ils encourent et toulon à d'autres clubs
on a le ba ba ba de chartres on va voilà
on a des clubs un peu partout en france
mais on voit là beaucoup beaucoup de la
région quand même les yvelinois ont
brillé dans cette compétition chez homme
quand un beau visage du club de
voisins-le-bretonneux a terminé à la
première place dans une finale 100% vie
sinoise face à romain meyniel chez les
filles juliette godard de montigny le
bretonneux a raflé la première place en
s'imposant au final compte e sandrine
l'homme de vitry enfin justino en vain
aux vins est monté sur la plus haute
marche du podium en remportant sa finale
contre au anne sophie duarte de chatou
en basket le chesnay versailles a été
battu par le mans lors de la 17e journée
de nationale 3 score final 89 à 70 les i
mean loi rate le coche dans la course au
maintien
le chesnay-versailles rester une
inquiétante 11e place avec 19 points
trapped n'a pas joué ce week-end et
reste à la septième place du classement
avec 24 points
en handball montigny-le-bretonneux a
réalisé la mauvaise opération du
week-end les filles de philippe les
tranches sont largement inclinés sur le
terrain de val d'orge sur le score de 34
à 28 lésigny montait n'ont pas su
concrétiser
leur action dans les temps forts
conséquence montigny retombe à la
troisième place du classement derrière
le havre et son adversaire du soir val
d'orge football mauvaise opération pour
magna magny les hameaux les joueurs de
farid gagny se sont inclinés 3 buts 1 à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de bailly
noisy le latéral gauche mauritanien
amadou tidjane tour et grande révélation
de cette première partie de saison du
côté de magny les hameaux n'a rien pu
faire
le club saint quentinois reste à la
première à la première place du
classement de 2e division de district
avec quatre points d'avancé sur le
second le chesnay toujours en foot ball
trap réalise une nouvelle fois une
contre-performance dans ce championnat
de promotion d'honneur les trappistes
ont concédé le match nul 1 but partout
sur leur terrain face à chanteloup les
vignes de précieux points s'envolent
pour trappe qui n'est pas encore sûr de
se maintenir dans ce championnat
de son côté chatou redescend la deuxième
place du classement après le succès de
parisi 2 0 face à la parisienne
on passe aux agendas du week-end il y
aura du handball ce samedi
montigny-le-bretonneux reçoit le paris
handball au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin ce samedi à 20h30
la victoire est impérative pour les
filles de philippe l'étrange ces
dernières viennent de perdre la première
place du classement de nationale 2 les
handballeuses auront à coeur de la
reprendre dès ce week end en rugby
plaisir reçoit l'ogre
saint-jean-d'angély ce dimanche à 15
heures la rencontre paraît déséquilibrée
sur le papier plaisir lutte pour le
maintien alors que saint jean d'angely
occupe la deuxième place du classement
un dernier petit mot de rugby avant de
refermer ce journal
hédi ben arous ce pilier gauche a connu
sa première titularisation samedi
dernier en équipe de france face à
l'irlande
né en 1990 à m 1990 à trappes il est
passé par l'école de rugby de trappe
avant de déménager à dreux il joue au
racing métro 92 depuis 2010 samedi
l'honorer sa troisième sélection en
équipe nationale c'est la fin de ce sept
huit sports je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur tv fil 78 et je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau magazine